foreign
last week the most overrated musical
artist in history released a new album
uh no John Lennon did not rise from the
grave he is after all only the second
most overrated artist in history the
crown belongs to the queen bee Beyonce
whose mediocre talents cannot on their
own even begin to explain the worshipful
praise her every breath receives now
she's not a bad singer exactly and she
is a relatively talented dancer but
there's nothing about her music sound or
output that's significantly
differentiates her from any other pop
star
yet music critics bow before her and
recite Psalms of Thanksgiving
sometimes they have to contort
themselves into even more tortured
shapes however as has been the case with
her new album Renaissance which just
came out last week she released the
first single break my soul a few weeks
ago and it sounds
well like this
[Music]
[Music]
now on the one hand it's inspiring that
she could compose a hit single on an old
Casio keyboard that she bought at a yard
sale but on the other hand the song is
just not very good I mean it sounds both
retro and perfunctory like a filler song
you might have heard dropped into the
middle of an Ace of Base album in 1995.
now it might make for some decent upbeat
hold music the kind of a thing that
keeps your spirits up while waiting for
the Comcast customer service agent to
come back on the line and tell you that
he can't fix whatever problem you're
having with your service but it's
certainly not the sort of music any
normal person would want to sit and
listen to on purpose
and the whole album is apparently filled
with stuff just like that which you can
tell based on the Hideous pretzel-like
shapes critics are assuming in order to
give the record a positive review I mean
they are desperate to find a way to
positively review this thing the
Atlantic for example calls the song or
rather the whole album
um a mess
says that the songs on the album clatter
wobble and lurch
and derives the whole effort as
indulgent childish exhausting and
ridiculous
and yet uses these adjectives in an
overall positive review
the critic concludes quote but
committing oneself to pleasure as fully
as Beyonce has here takes Defiance and
guts and more deeply faith in the
preciousness of One's Own experience
somehow she has found a way to make
messages of individual empowerment which
can be so trite in pop jolt again
plus he notes the album is very gay and
so that earns at a five-star rating all
on its own but even a big gay album even
one produced by Beyonce
the queen of all creation
is not exempt from the woke mob
Beyonce's team this week had to release
a statement and retroactively change one
of the songs on the album after
receiving intense backlash for the use
of an ableist slur
as many outlets including Yahoo have
reported the song heated off of the
Renaissance album contains the slur spaz
which yeah which Yahoo notes quote is a
derogatory term for [ __ ] diplegia a
form of cerebral palsy which makes it
difficult for people to control some
muscles
because obviously you know when someone
uses the word spaz they're intending to
refer to [ __ ] diplegia
indeed they're intending to insult and
demean everybody with the spat with with
a [ __ ] diplegia
this is obviously the meaning behind the
word and why it must be denounced and
renounced and erased from any book film
or song where it occurs
now if this all sounds like deja vu to
you that's not because you're going
insane it's because the world is going
insane because yes if you recall lizzo
another once Immaculate and sinless
musical genius and poet had to change
one of her songs a couple of months ago
because it also contained the word that
we've just decided now as a slur
now what this shows us is that wokeness
itself
is now the god
Beyonce and her ilk have been basically
demoted
they are now merely priests and
priestesses of of the religion
they're not the gods themselves all must
bow before the woke Altar and make their
offerings
virtue signaling is a requirement from
which none are exempt
now this may seem like a positive
development of sorts as it ensures that
the people who promote this ideology
will be forced to take their own
medicine but it's less positive when you
realize that wokeness is mass hysteria
now it is just an avalanche of stupidity
and Insanity that nobody controls
that to me was the most Salient and
important point in the latest
controversy where people are once again
spazzing out over the stupidest
imaginable thing but then
I went and listened to the portion of
the song that contains this allegedly
offensive lyric
my eardrums have yet to recover from the
experience and now yours will suffer the
same fate I'm afraid here it is listen
your face
goes quick dimples on my hips
Chanel
now
when I hear lyrics like yummy yummy yum
make that bummy heated make a pretty
girl talk that
whiskey till I'm tipsy glitter on my
kitty cool it down down down my pretty
bad bad make the bad bad glitchy fine
fine fine fine fine
Liberated Living like we ain't got time
yada yada yada yada yada yada yada
spazzing on that ass spaz on that Ass
Fan be quick girl I need my glass when I
hear those lyrics
I am not especially offended by the word
spaz I can barely hear the word by the
time we've made it to that part because
I've been reduced to a nearly catatonic
state
the idiocy in the song is so potent so
pure so uncut that I have overdosed on
it this is medical grade stupidity you
can actually feel your head start to
throb and burn as your brain cells
self-immolate in protest
listen to this on repeat for 30 minutes
would have the same neurological effect
as a lobotomy that's a scientific fact
but even on just one brief listen the
song is dumb enough to provoke a
full-fledged existential crisis causing
the listener to question the very
purpose and meaning of human existence
it's the worst thing I've ever heard and
yet it's also indistinguishable from 95
of pop music it all bleeds together into
one putrid toxic malignant cancerous
lump
now it seems trite I understand to
complain
about dumb pop music
but that's only because we take for
granted that most popular music will be
aggressively ear bleedingly bad
but we really shouldn't take this for
granted it's a very modern predicament
that most of our artists produce vulgar
inane disgusting rubbish that is
essentially the auditory equivalent of
drinking stagnant water out of a trash
can lid it was not always this way it
wasn't artists through history have had
varying degrees of talent and Genius of
course but they've all been artists at
least they have strived historically to
produce things that are beautiful and
true
an important
artists have not historically been a
class of wealthy semi-literate
self-aggrandizing donkeys this is a
situation peculiar to the Modern Age
and like most things that are peculiar
to our age we assume that it's always
been this way and will always remain
this way and so we don't react to it the
way we should and how should we react
well probably the most reasonable
response to a song like that is to vomit
all over yourself
but a slightly cleaner and more subtle
reaction would be to recoil and disgust
and to be offended not in a petty
oversensitive kind of way but in the
deeper and and more righteous sense of
the term offended by the vulgar
stupidity and shamelessness of these pop
industry parasites who wish to make our
children Dumber while feeding on their
souls and their minds like some kind of
brain eating amoeba
most of all we should dispense with the
notion
that art and Beauty are entirely
subjective they're not right as if the
Sistine Chapel and a smiley face smeared
in feces on the wall of a padded cell
have equal artistic legitimacy as if a
sane person could be justified in
preferring either one
no far from subjective Beauty and art
are transcendent
I mean beauty is truth it's eternal
to understand this fact is to take one
of the most important red pills you can
take
but you can't do that
until you ditch all of this pop music
garbage
starting with Beyonce who is awful and
stupid
and talentless and terrible
and most essential especially today she
is canceled
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the Subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast